yesterday was the deadline for putting
the franchise tag
on any player whose contract will
otherwise expire
on wednesday march 17 at 4 pm
eastern now let's just enter this
discussion acknowledging
what the franchise tag is whatever word
you apply to you can call it anything
you want
it's a device for the teams to keep
players
from getting to the open market and
maximizing
their compensation specifically into
that second year guaranteed money into
that second year you always get less
under the franchise tag unless you've
got general managers owners coaches you
don't know what the hell you're doing
the player is getting less than he
otherwise could have gotten by hitting
the open market this isn't a good thing
we explained that last week it's not a
positive thing it's not an
honor it's not some sort of distinction
or designation that the player gets a
trophy for
it's a thing that keeps a player from
getting what he should be getting or at
least delaying it for now
so with that said chris yeah 10
franchise tags were extended
on tuesday and let's dispense with
dak prescott right out of the gates we
talked about this yesterday
that was done at his
mandate at his directive to ensure that
he'll never be tagged again
that's the first time that i think this
has ever happened where a guy does a
long-term deal
before the deadline for applying the tag
and he gets the team to apply the tag
anyway
because it helps in his quest to never
be tagged again right
no i've never seen that i don't i mean
you know let me in general first off i
mean that was
a smooth move uh by dak prescott his
representation
all of that certainly and you know back
to the franchise thing too yeah it
drives me crazy just to make one comment
on that i don't like the franchise tag
is the ex player of course i don't
why would i like the franchise tag it's
the only business in the world
that has anything similar to that hey
you're one of the best there is out
there
but we're not going to give you any
long-term security we're going to screw
you over in one of the riskiest
businesses
you know there is out there and i
understand they're going to make a big
chunk of change
but it's still about market price and
that's where i just i hate
i hate the franchise tag because it
really does limit players and their
ability
sometimes to get that big payday get
that long-term security
and not have to worry about oh i got
injured and now everything's you know
down the drain
you know we've been doing this for three
and a half years yeah
eventually later this year before that's
how the passage of time works
i think i'm starting to get you to come
around
on my notion that the draft is
anti-american and there's no other
industry in which incoming employees
are distributed that way here because at
the core of what you just said about the
franchise tag is the same concern
there's no other business
where the employees get treated this way
you're punished
for your success you're restricted
because you're good
you're due to earn so you can't that's
the franchise tag and chris here's
here's the reality right from time to
time i'll hear
union or players or whoever say well the
franchise tags got to go
well it's not going anywhere because
first of all the league has to put it on
the table for negotiation
within the confines of cba discussions
right second of all
if it ever would be on the table think
about the value that it has to a team
think about the value it has to the
league in holding down salary because
every guy that you tag is one less guy
who can stretch that rubber
band as far as possible and pull others
with him
because now he's got a new record high
contract that he gets on the open market
the value of the tag to the league
would make the concession that the union
would have to give
to get the league to give up the tag
astronomical
so it's never going away it's
always going to be part watch they'll
get rid of it next year now that i said
that but i believe it's
always going to be part of the fabric of
the nfl because it's been there and one
last point
we were texting about this in the
aftermath of that great photo of the
quarterback club with
steve young on his tiptoes like
cristiano ronaldo and
and and phil with his hands on jim
everett's shoulders and
just a great picture with zubaz print
everywhere right
that was the quarterback club that
emerged in the aftermath of the shutting
down of the union after the failed 1987
strike there was a great antitrust
lawsuit led by reggie white the the
the players had the league on the ropes
and they settled for this cba that has
the franchise tag in it
i'm a firm believer they should have
kept pushing they should have kept going
and going and going and going and maybe
there would have never been a franchise
tag so
that's where it came from from that
antitrust litigation
and it's never leaving and we just have
to deal with it but it's not a day of
celebration
for the players it's a day of
celebration for the ones who aren't
tagged it's not a day of celebration for
the ones who are
no it's not you know there it's a little
bit of like oh man i'm not gonna get a
long-term contract
there is a little bit of weight i
am the franchise guy where you do feel
special
you know i mean of course that there was
that thought in the locker room as i was
playing like to go hey i'm
i'm the franchise guy they're willing to
give me that money and do that
but still that's not what you want as a
player even though that guy could wear
that as a badge of honor and yeah i'm
making a lot of money this one year and
hey i'm obviously important to the team
i'm the one guy they franchised
nobody wants it so yes and again i'm not
trying to sound like a spoiled brat
and make players sound like spoiled
brats too they're not spoiled i'm not
spoiled i know but they're entitled to
make
every last penny they can get i know but
i'm just you know i'm going to buy
if you read the comments under some
article you write about this on pro
football don't talk ready where i know
but that's where all spoiled players and
all the all they do is
play football i know screw them or is
right okay they're entitled to their
opinion but we're entitled to say screw
them yes okay
they're just wrong yes all right okay
cool and those are the ones that don't
get deleted those are the ones that make
it past the screeners
uh you can imagine what people will say
under the
cloak of anonymity that comes from
comments and
now we're starting down another track i
mean speaking about pouring liquid into
the trash can we've
come so close to pouring the comments
section into the trash can and
that's an ongoing discussion and who
knows that may be floating around
somewhere with your liquid all right
stay on target pete's telling me
come on pete making the star wars
reference although my my tweet to
announce that the show was starting is
also a star wars reference so i can't
give pete a hard time for that here we
go beyond dak prescott
finally we're getting there the tags
were distributed to nine different
players
and let's just talk through them as they
pop up let's start with the guys tagged
for the second straight year
those are the guys who are either going
to get long-term deals by july 15 or
they will be free agents next year
because the franchise tag for
alan not alan robinson's not second
straight here he
he uh brandon sherff leonard williams
justin
is our second straight year alan
robinson we need to fix that graphic
pete says it's his mistake pete
apparently was not staying on target
when he was putting this graphic
together take that chop so sure sheriff
leonard williams and justin simmons
they're not going to get tagged next
year so it's either long-term deal or
they're going to be walking away in free
agency after two years of being tagged
chris
and uh you know it's a big price tag
it's 20 raise over their tag from last
year but it just shows you
what the teams think of these guys and
it shows you
how important it is to be able to keep
these guys from walking away to the
highest bidder and these teams don't
want to have to worry about someone else
paying more for the services of these
three players no definitely not and all
three of those players are like
huge parts of their football team you
know they all they kind of
they got they got the teams backed into
a corner a little bit because of the
situation brandon sheriff let's just
start there he is one of the best guards
in football
and then even with the second year
franchise tag
you know it is not a number that you
look at and go
well this is ridiculous that they're
paying him no
it's really it's not far off from what
if he signs a long-term deal
what his average per year contract will
be so to me that was a no-brainer with
brandon sherf
and and doing that um he's too good of a
football player you don't let that guy
walk out the door leonard williams
you know again we know a really good
football player but he's got the
leverage in the thing you've talked
about many many times
you know whether it was jaylen ramsey or
a few other guys
where they get traded a team gives up
you know a decent haul for the guy
and now he's played really well and
he's one of the few guys that can
pressure the quarterback on the football
team in fact he's really the only guy
everybody else we've talked about it's
it's about
size their physical up front with the
giants but he's the true disrupter of
the group
so yeah they keep him and i understand
that he's the only presence they got
on the outside edge of the line and he's
versatile can move inside and do a lot
of things there
and we talked about justin simmons
yesterday who i think is one of the
three
best safeties in football uh without
question
and with him with the vic fangio scheme
and all that and again
you know mike you look at that number
and go okay even what he's making for a
second-year franchise tag number
it's not astronomical to where you go oh
that's crazy for one year for a free
safety again
when you match it up with the other top
average salaries at the position
it's right there with it so to me that
it made sense
and i would think like i would think
sherf
and simmons for sure are
have a good chance of getting a
long-term deal done the leonard williams
one i think might be a little tricky and
you know the reality is all these guys
should have their long-term deal
last year in the form of either leaving
through free agency or having their
teams compete with these other
franchises and paying
more money to keep them around and
giving them more security and to get the
second tag that meant they had to
survive the injury risk right last year
survived the risk that maybe they
weren't going to be as desirable because
trust me none of these guys would have
been tagged a second time if their teams
didn't say
we must keep them based upon how they
performed last year not well you know
what we did the franchise tag it's you
know
he he regressed and now we're going to
let him leave these are all players who
are highly desired by their teams and
they are
sticking around so those are the three
that were tagged a second time
and again july 15 the clock now ticks
toward that date as the deadline for a
long-term deal couple of receivers
got tagged one not a surprise the other
to me a surprise let's start with
alan robinson the bears receiver we saw
this coming we knew this was coming we
sensed it was coming
the bears don't have a bunch of great
players on offense they're scrambling to
find a quarterback whoever their
quarterback
is and what a feeling that's got to be
for alan robinson hey i'm going to be
with the team this year
i don't have any idea who the
quarterback's gonna pay no i mean
tough spot for him there's no commitment
for a long-term salary at least he's
been disgruntled by that really
since the halfway point of last year we
started to hear those rumblings right
and you said it right mike i mean he's
one of the few
real maybe only blue chipper on the
whole offense
to where you go wait wait this guy we we
got to look at him and
game plan for him a little bit and we
got to make sure in certain situations
we got the right match up
you know again i don't look at him as a
top five receiver in football allen
robinson but he's one of those guys
that's in that top 10
conversation you know like we talked
about last year there's 20 receivers
that you could say are in the top 10
conversation
but but yes either way he's
their most dangerous weapon on the
offense and
you know again a team that seems in flux
right now about what to do and are they
going to make a move for russell wilson
or desean watson and all those type of
things
you can't let him hit the free agent
market they need to keep him in case
they maybe want to use them as you know
part of an asset to trade them as well
so for me that was a no-brainer made a
lot of sense that they kept allen
robinson
not easy to trade a franchise tag player
he has to be fully on board with it he
has to sign his franchise tender first
and foremost
because you can't trade a guy who is on
the tag but has yet to accept the tag
and then after that
the new team is going to want a
long-term deal most likely they don't
want to step into the shoes of the
franchise tag team
and that makes it something that only is
going to happen
if the player wants to do it and you
talk about the prospect of trading alan
robinson
if he would go to seattle with tyler
lockett and dk metcalf
that that would be strange
to say the least to have him at it now
it'd make for a great receiving corps
but if you're a
pass catcher and you want to catch
passes and they don't know who the
seahawks quarterback is going to be but
they got dk metcalf allen robinson and
tyler lockett
it just seems like robinson wouldn't get
the kind of of production that he had
this past year when he had 102
receptions
for 1250 yards and robinson i i just
asked the
the crew that works with me at pft if
this has happened before
how how often it happens because i think
this is a rarity
where a guy gets franchise tagged
not on the completion of his rookie
contract this is a guy
who finished his four-year rookie deal
in jacksonville
left as a free agent yeah spent three
years with the bears
and now is getting tagged after seven
nfl seasons and two teams usually it's
four or five years out after you've been
drafted that's when you get franchise
tagged by the team that drafted you so
i'm curious if there's some way to
research that
and see how many guys are like this i
think phil dawson has been in that boat
but
if you set aside kickers and punters i
don't think guys you could say
barrett well that's right exactly that's
a good one
denver four years went to tampa for a
year
got tagged so that's another guy who has
moved as a free agent already yeah
but then had the door slammed in his
face so maybe it's not as rare
as i'm thinking i think it is i think
you're right the usual path is finish
your rookie contract and get tagged or
not tagged chris godwin
the guy who got tagged in tampa instead
of
shaq barrett that's what surprised me
and when i saw the news that the bucks
were going to
tag receiver chris godwin a guy that i
thought they could afford to let walk
away given the depth at the position
and they needed to keep barrett i
thought well we're going to hear that
later today
shaq barrett has a long-term deal
they're talking but he doesn't have a
long-term deal
so they may see shaq barrett walk away
in free agency chris because they have
no way to keep him
from leaving now that they used their
one and only one tag on chris godwin no
it's uh that was the i think the splash
of the day
you know added to right first they got
the levante david contract we saw that
get done and you went whoa okay
that's not a crazy price pretty
manageable for what they did there
wow big great job by jason light in the
bucks re-signing levante david there you
go
and then yeah i expected to hear
shaquille barrett
as as the franchise guy as well um
either way chris godwin is worthy of
being tagged he is that type of talent
there's no doubt about that
and he's just hitting the prime of his
career so he's got lots of years in
front of him
and i'm sure they don't want to see him
walk out the door but when you get into
like the conversation too about
shaq barrett yeah it's either like
it's either one they felt like
okay we're gonna get a deal done with
him that's pretty manageable
or it's two holy crap he's really priced
himself out of this
and this is an issue here and i don't
know if we're gonna resign them and i i
don't know
i have no inside info on where that goes
but to me that's at least the the two
things that that seem to be apparent
here i don't know have you got any feel
for that
well i i i was surprised
that that godwin got the tag yeah
because they already have mike evans
right and they're paying him
a significant amount rarely can you see
a team
afford to put that much money into two
receivers they can do it for one
yeah but you typically can't do it for
two it's not unprecedented
but it's hard to do it for two secondly
with so many great young receivers every
year now coming out in the draft i feel
like
dollar for dollar yeah and every team
goes through this exercise dollar for
dollar
you can't justify tying up that much
money in a position where
look they found tyler johnson last year
and they like tyler johnson you bump him
up and you
backfill with another rookie and you've
got scottie miller a guy that you
drafted
and or was even undrafted i don't have
to look that up but a young guy who's
still working his way through the system
who isn't making much money drafted or
not he's not making much money
dollar for dollar that's what you have
to ask yourself and
that's what stunned me now with shaq
barrett it very well could be that he
wants so much
that like you said they just they just
know they can't do it right
and we've we've mentioned a few times
how many pass rushers
are hitting the market they can just do
what they did two years ago when they
signed shaq barrett
he he comes in as a stranger and he has
19 sacks no
so they'll find another pass rusher to
come in maybe you can get two or three
pass rushers
for less than what it would cost to keep
shaq barrett for a year
no i i mean you're right mike you you
made that point
on on text yesterday and when you said
it i went
ooh that's a really good point there's
that that might be part of the equation
you're right with the fact that if he's
asking for some huge you know and what
was his going to be his franchise tag
going 18.99 18.99 million so i don't
know what he's asking for
but there is a lot of guys
out there like you're talking about on
the edge
right who won't be able to command
shaquille barrett type money
and you know he's a guy again you know
he was a middle round pick if i remember
correctly coming out of colorado state
drafted by denver
doing all that he's just starting to
make money so he might be one of those
guys that
looks at it and goes you know listen i
love the bucks and i'd love to be here
for a winter but it's
it's time for you know big daddy here to
get paid right
he so he might be one of those that goes
i don't i need the money i want i want
some security some long-term stuff and
all that
and that becomes an issue okay but then
yes to your point
you know there's a there's guys out
there like leonard floyd for an example
and and a lot of other players to where
you go wow that's a really good player
that's not going to be able to command
18 million dollars a year or anything in
that ballpark
and i i think that makes a lot of sense
and i can see that you know yannick and
gawkway can he command that kind of
money out on the free on the market i
don't think so not at this point it's a
good
good chunk of change and i don't expect
it to be him but just adding to your
point there are a lot of good edge pass
rushers out there
and that's what's amazing because we are
reminded from time to time specifically
in the super bowl how
important it is to have great pass
rushers and then we kind of forget about
it and then we're reminded of it again
by some dominant pass rushing
performance in the super bowl so this is
a valuable position i would put
quarterback pass rusher tackle i don't
know how do you rank that well as
overall value is it is pass rusher more
valuable than a tackle i think so
i do yes yeah yeah i think i look at
that and just go
a pass rusher an elite pass rusher can
affect the game in so many ways
and tackle of course is very important
for all the reasons to block those guys
but
man a really elite defense and you know
they affect the run game they can be
great that way and then of course
the the amount of forget the sacks and
things like that it's the disruption
it's the quarterback pressures
everything that that helps the secondary
so i i would say that's probably the
number two thing on my list too
and that's what makes it amazing that so
many of them are going to be floating
around and that's got to be factoring
into the buccaneers thinking this isn't
something they just randomly did this
isn't just
well tommy wants his receiver here so we
have to keep the receiver and we'll just
have to figure something out on defense
defense has to be a priority their
defense has been
a key part of that championship run
that defense helped them in many
situations that defense kept the packers
from parlaying three consecutive tom
brady interceptions
into a victory what would have been a
stunning come from behind victory they
were down 28 to 10 green bay was
the defense stiffened on two of those
three
drives and kept the packers from taking
the lead and then we know what happened
we have a down at the end of his prime
i assume that was one of the drives from
uh resulting from one of the
interceptions
where they almost uh scored the the
touchdown and didn't go forward
and didn't go for it on fourth down yeah
so um defense important but maybe
they think they can find another shaq
barrett and not have to pay that kind of
money barrett did say
not that long ago he wants to break the
bank so we know
we know that his objective is to get
paid maximum dollars
and to get maximum dollars he may have
to go somewhere i i that that's where
when you really look at it and you hear
those comments
and just that that was my first thought
like i said that he might be
asking for you know they realized man
it's this is going to be a one-year
thing and he's out of here because he's
looking to break the bank and
listen from shaquille barrett's
standpoint he can look at other defense
ends in football right now
and go wait i've been better than these
guys for three years now
and they're making a ton of money and
here i'll just throw out some names
i mean he certainly can look at demarcus
lawrence and frank clark
who i you know i got a lot of respect
for frank clark on what he does
but he can look at them realistically
and go wait
i've been better than them for two or
three years now he can look at trey
flowers who went from new england to the
detroit lions who's making 18 million
dollars a year and go i'm definitely
better than him
there's there's no doubt about it i so i
affect the game in more areas and do all
those type of things
so from that standpoint you look at it
and yeah i look at shaquille barrett and
i'm not mad at him if he's asking for 20
million dollars a year
north of that for where the market is
and things like that and he's the next
guy up and all of that
so it'll be interesting to watch what
happens with him here as we go along and
and you know it's not just looking at
the guys who are going to hit the market
it's considering the guys
who may still yet hit the market von
miller and the broncos have yet to
figure out their situation the broncos
obviously and reportedly want von miller
to take less than 18 million dollars
this year
if he hits the market we don't know what
kind of conversations he and tom brady
have been having you know there's all
sorts of
tampering that isn't really tampering
that happens among players
the idea of tom and vaughn
reuniting or uniting they've never been
united before except on opposite sides
of the ball
in tampa you know that that that's just
one of the paths
that the buccaneers can take it is and
that's where the challenge becomes
forgetting who the guy is forgetting
what he's done and saying we got to make
a good decision and the other side of
this too and this may be why barrett
wants so much money i mean he knows what
else is out there
all it takes is one owner to to say
i want that guy i want that guy i want
that guy
and you know what his team is going to
pay that guy
and and that that getting that guy who
was part of a super bowl run and making
him the centerpiece of your free agency
class and also
hurting the buccaneers or thinking
you're hurting the buccaneers that's
part of this game too
there's a strong business component the
free agency you know i've seen
every every year at this time we see the
articles and the analyses which point to
a conclusion that we already know
you don't build a championship team in
free agency by spending big money no you
do it by being smart and waiting for the
market to settle and shopping for
bargains
but you build a successful financial
operation
in part by creating excitement
by going out and overpaying a free agent
because you get season ticket renewals
you sell jerseys you take attention away
from other
leagues teams in other leagues in your
market there are business reasons
for it to happen that are independent of
whether or not it's ever going to help
you win a super bowl and
that's part of the reality and even in a
year with a reduced cap chris
there's going to be teams that want to
make that splash especially as we
recover from the pandemic
we start thinking about selling tickets
for 2021
it helps to sell tickets if you can say
we got shaq barrett away from the tampa
bay buccaneers no no doubt about that
there is that aspect
some teams looking to make a splash just
get you know in the good favor of the
the fans
get a little hype and propaganda going
about hey we're doing the right things
as an organization here
we're trying to win and do that and that
could very easily be shaq barrett he
would fit that mold
too to where you might not you're not
gonna have to pay him to be the highest
paid defensive end in the history of
football or anything like that
but you're gonna be able to give him a
splash contract and go look you see what
he did did you see all those highlights
of him chasing down the homes and all
over them and
did you see all those big sacks he had
against aaron rodgers in that game yet
the guy's big time he shows up in big
moments and that will excite a fan base
to what you're saying
all right uh some other guys who were
tagged for the offensive line other than
brandon sheriff taylor moton
panthers and cam robinson jaguars couple
of teams that entered the league
together in 1995. moton not a surprise
cam
a mild surprise although the possibility
of cam robinson being tagged was on the
radar screen and urban meyer explained
yesterday the thought process there
you know the new coaching staff looked
carefully at cam robinson decided they
needed to keep him and they've got the
cap space to do it
so they're keeping him from hitting free
agency yeah i mean
that that was a surprise to me but when
you break it down and what urban meyer
said
you know again it goes into a little bit
of like it's the overall state of the
offensive line that i think gets taken
to an account here
where urban meyer looks at it and goes
wait you know a little bit like allen
robinson with the bearish he goes well
this is
this is the really only quality
offensive lineman we got on the football
team here
everything else is a little bit you know
dicey here
there's no like mainstay dominant
football player and cam robinson's
real good is he worth you know franchise
tag
type money not to me he's not um
but when you take in the current you
know situation and the things he's
talking about he's trying to build
something he's gonna draft trevor
lawrence
well okay we got a pretty good one that
we think can make we can make him better
to draft and protect trevor lawrence and
do those type of things so from all that
standpoint
it makes sense yeah i don't think he's
one of the three or four or five best
tackles in football
i don't and i think most people would
agree with that so that was a little bit
of a surprise but i think when you take
in the whole team and roster into
account
it does make sense for what urban said
safeties also got tagged yesterday
beyond justin simmons
marcus williams of the saints that was a
surprise
marcus may of the jets was not uh and
what surprised me about the saints all
the cap issues we're talking about i
figured they'd be the last team to
consider using the tag on anyone i i
went through this exercise on my
my podcast like two weeks ago and we
talked about marcus
williams and now he's a guy that is
worthy of the franchise tag but i didn't
think they would do it not with the
current state of where they're at i mean
holy cow do they got a lot of work to do
in new orleans what are they going to do
here
you know i know you can make it work and
do a lot of stuff but
they are where where is their current
status mike right now as far as the
salary cap
i mean it's way way over still i mean
way over i i want to say it's
there we go here's pete johnny on the
spot yeah i was gonna say it's close to
60 million
wow so that's they got a lot of fat to
trim
holy cow and now i'm gonna be interested
to see who goes by the wayside and what
they can do to make this happen
well i know one guy that very well could
be gone in the next week and that's
marshon lattimore he's got an
eight-figure salary in his option year
coming up it becomes fully guaranteed
on the first day of the league year
unless he takes less he could be gone
that's an easy way to take a chunk out
of that but you still got a lot more
that you have to do
a lot of work that needs to be done
they've been restructuring contracts and
they're still in that spot now the
problem this time of year
is that the the numbers like the one we
just put up doesn't always reflect
recent efforts to reduce the cap so
you know they're getting closer they're
doing what they can and mickey loomis
who received plenty of praise
on twitter yesterday for somehow someway
figuring it out and that's the reality
they will find a way to figure
it out they'll do whatever they have to
do what period
and if they have to just cut guys
they're going to cut guys well that's
where you look at it all right and you
just try to look at okay who's the guys
that
got a big cat you know cap hit and
there's a good difference between the
cap hit
and the dead money and what there is
there to be had
you talked about marshawn lattimore uh
okay yeah that's right they could they
could take a huge chunk off
like you said 10 million dollars a look
at januris jenkins who played really
good football last year
but they could save around 7 million
with him tyron
armstead yeah real good left tackle but
has been
injured and getting up there in years
they can save another 7 million with him
are they going to make those type of
moves that's what i'm interested to see
here for mickey loomis sean payton and
kind of how they orchestrate their team
here going forward and
it just looks to me on the outside
looking in that they're going to have to
make some uncomfortable moves here and
cut some guys that they don't want to
cut
but that's just the reality of the
situation one thing that i've been
looking at is the possibility of a
michael thomas
trade yeah because remember there was
some discussion along those lines when
the
the relationship went south during the
season but if they would trade him
pre uh prejudice
they are looking at my gosh they are
looking at 20 million dollars in
acceleration yeah
so yeah they would avoid 12 million or
so
in payment to him almost 13 million in
payment but you're going to take a 20
million
cap charge to trade him post june 1 they
could pull it off
but uh that that's a guy that's going to
be very hard to to chop his down but you
basically have to go
player by player line by line contract
by contract and see
what fat can we trim here what can we do
here to maybe push some money into
future years
or get a guy to take a a pay cut where
we're not moving money around or just
get rid of the guy altogether
and then what are the cap consequences
if he's traded or if he's released and
that's what a good general manager has
to do
the problem this year for every team and
specifically for the teams that already
were going to be pressed up against the
cap
you've got 15.7 million left that's the
less that's the expected drop
right i'm told it's almost definitely
going to be 182.5 that's 15.7
less than what it was going to be so
it's going to make it more of a
challenge
drew brees did them a hell of a favor by
dropping his base salary from 25 to the
minimum of 1.075 but even then
even then that was just that was just
the first cut
they still have a lot to do to get this
figured
out um and and now they've got an
eight-figure salary that will be devoted
to marcus williams
that they they need to get figured out
and and here's the other side of it too
until he signs it they could rescind it
if they wanted to they're not
bound by this if they if they just get
to a point where
we can't get from here to there right as
they're figuring out the cap
and they need another 10 million they
just rescind the tag you know josh
williams right as as long as he doesn't
sign it once he signs it and if you're
marcus williams
you may want to think about yeah you
know checkmate here right
saying i want i'll take that i'll take
that eight-figure salary
but uh they could always pull it away
and that could be a way that they
that they help get to where they are but
yeah it's not going to be easy a lot of
sleepless nights for
mickey loomis and his staff coming up
over the course of the next week yeah
really i mean it really is and again
there's still a team that you look at
and go wow they're a quality football
team
yeah they're a year older but even
without drew brees i expect the saints
to be
very relevant next year um but but i
mean
you got to see how this all shakes out
because they're going to have to make
some tough decisions i don't know if
that's going to be via
trade things like that whatever but
they're going to have to get real
creative here as creative as i can
remember
any top team in the league here in
recent history i mean correct me if i'm
wrong mike but i just
i was kind of trying to think about it
you know on the drive in here to the
show today like i don't remember a team
like a saints you know upper echelons
cream of the crop type of football there
we go yep i'm getting there
uh no you're not you said i'm bracelet
right
a lot you're right upper echelon sorry
sorry it's
rolls-off echelon lawn there's no
i don't care if i ever get it right so
don't worry some of these things we fix
with one some it's a process we got him
to take the
s off of upper echelons
now we gotta get him to drop the t and
just call it upper echelon that's the
next one but do you remember a team
ever like uh that has not like this
right right well
well i remember a team like the titans
at one point where
they just accepted that for this year
they were in cap purgatory
so you know there are certain things
they couldn't do and
uh you know i remember teams scrambling
to make sure they had enough
cap space left to sign their draft picks
you know that that used to be pre-2006
really that used to be an issue it
started to subside after the 2006 cba
and after 2011 you rarely hear of it the
steelers and the cowboys are really the
only teams you ever hear
of having to scramble to create cap
space and this whole idea of
restructuring contracts
you you don't avoid the cap dollars you
just push them into future years but as
the cap keeps going up and up and up
those dollars have a lower relative
value there's deflation
because a dollar today under this cap
means a hell of a lot less under a
future cap when there's more
dollars to spend and that's what teams
do that's part of what the saints are
going to have to do push money into
future years of course one of the
problems is
past money from drew brees pushed into
this year
that's one of the reasons why they're in
this mess when you kick the can
at some point there's a reckoning and if
the cap drops
that's when the reckoning arrives yeah
chris's reckoning is arriving at least
the first phase of it because
he multitasked during the first segment
unless someone else posted the tweet the
poll
so far now this is very very early
returns that's only 125 votes
we're up to 1900 and it's worse it's
81.9 percent
know you monster on the question of
whether it's okay
to pour liquid into a trash can your
first response though
says yes as long as i'm the one who has
to take out the trash thank you very
much
dan turco with an umlaut over the oh so
that may not be turkey
where i don't buy this i don't buy this
bullcrap here right here okay i think we
got a lot of twitter
users right now that are are you kidding
me how many of them throw
in like you know a huge thing a coke
uh a 32 ounce or big gulp or something
like that and they throw it away with 10
ounces left in there
that's some baloney i don't think people
are being real about this
i think they're being accurate and i
think they're being reasonable and i
think they're being fair to whoever has
to deal
with the mess that is left in the trash
can
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports